les études démontrent qu'avec un système
de garderie abordable il ya une
augmentation de l'activité économique
et il ya plus d'argent qu'ils retournent
dans le coffre des gouvernements
vérification faite c'est vrai si on se
fie à l'expérience québécoise
le npd fait référence à une étude de la
chaire de recherche en fiscalité et en
finances publiques de l'université de
sherbrooke
la conclusion de cette étude tous les
ordres de gouvernement ont réalisé pour
2008 seulement un solde excédentaire de
919 millions de dollars en mettant sur
pied un système de garderie plus
abordable au québec
alors c'est non seulement quelque chose
on peut se permettre d'avoir c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas se
permettre de ne pas avoir
explications en 2008 la disponibilité de
services de garde à contribution réduite
à inciter près de 70000 mer à retourner
sur le marché du travail et le taux
d'activité chez les femmes a grimpé en
flèche par rapport à celui des autres
canadiennes
ces femmes ont payé des impôts sur leurs
revenus et le produit intérieur brut a
augmenté le 5 milliards de dollars en
autre bienfait selon une étude du centre
interuniversitaire de recherche en
analyse des organisations
le revenu disponible de certains ménages
s'en trouve augmentée
le système de garderies du québec n'est
pas pour autant parfait et au fil des
ans il a été victime de son succès les
coûts ont explosé et la disponibilité
des places subventionnées est souvent
limitée ici louis philippe ouimet radio
canada montréal